. Hey, David, Joe Biden keeps talking about
compromising with Republicans and working
across the aisle.
Is Biden nuts for thinking this Republican
Party will compromise with him?
Well, this this requires some speculation
about what Biden actually thinks and believes.
What I mean by that is I don't know that Joe
Biden really thinks this Republican Party
is going to work with him.
And in fact, I doubt he thinks that.
I believe Joe Biden is talking about reaching
across the aisle and getting Republicans to
compromise because he's trying to be a unifying
figure who at least appears willing to reach
out to.
Republican voters, it makes them look presidential,
it appeals to more than just the Democratic
Party and it in a way puts pressure on Republicans.
Many are friends with Biden.
Remember, Biden has a lot of Republican friends
to try to rise above partizanship.
But my belief is Biden knows, especially because
they've been clear Republicans will be obstructionist
buffoons for the next at least two years,
likely for they will try to get in the way
of any accomplishment that the Democratic
Party tries to do.
And so I don't believe Joe Biden's rhetoric
about bipartisanship and compromise will go
anywhere.
I think with this Republican Party, the only
the only way to get them to work with Biden
would be to make such significant concessions
that these legislative victories would end
up being Pyrrhic victories.
In other words, victories in which you you
you are so much damage is inflicted upon you
that you start to wonder, is it really even
a victory in the net?
So I think, you know, if I believed Biden
naively believed Mitch McConnell is going
to help him get the tax reform done that he
wants, and the public option of that would
be insanely naive of Joe Biden.
But I don't think he believes that.
I believe it's mostly posturing.
I believe Joe Biden knows because Republicans
have made it clear they will obstruct absolutely
everything that they can.
And I'm not particularly optimistic that Republicans
are going to participate in anything over
the next four years.
So what can Joe Biden get done without Republicans?
What can Joe Biden get done with executive
orders?
It remains to be seen and will be here for
the ride.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Make sure you're signed up for a membership
at Join Pakman Dotcom.
We have a new coupon code, better 21.
The meaning should be obvious.
We want to have a better twenty twenty one
than twenty twenty better twenty one.
You can sign up now and be listening or watching
today's bonus show within 60 seconds.
I promise you join Pakman Dotcom coupon code
better twenty one.